the chair wishes to thank all of you who
came here instead of going to the Taylor
this is a meeting of the Health and
Human Services oversight committee on
Friday May 19
2023 would the clerk please call the
roll
representative Pearson here
represent McDonald
representative Weber
representative King here representative
Edwards here representative Merchant
here
representative Murphy
Senator Rosenwald excused absence
they got this thing called a budget
oh all three of them well I don't know
about
right it's the greatest chairman of it
Senator gray and senator
hey Bart I've not heard anything from
him okay so
good thank you uh if you haven't seen it
already please take a look at the draft
minutes
mm-hmm
which which opens the question so what I
mean if do we let's send everyone home
or or do we just not just kind of Nod
that the minutes look good to us and
I've not been a stickler on that
we can so we have exactly
okay who can I swear chairman John
Williams if I could just uh
and you want to be a member for Quorum
purposes not exactly uh chairman uh but
what I wanted to bring to your attention
you actually and under statute have
eight members so the four plus one is
five there are two alternates that serve
uh on this committee as well is this
your way of saying we have a quorum
yes
take a look please at the Menace of the
we have a second second thank you and I
think we have kind of looked at them
some of this that floated by us in email
and I give a minute for anybody to
may I you may okay so on at the very top
of the second page it continues with
developmental disabilities inquired
brain disorder and the bullet is the DD
weightless I I I think there was a
relevant discussion about continuing to
expand upon the information shared with
this committee relative to the real wait
list and not just the the funded wait
list we've we've had reported for quite
some time that we fully funded the DD
waitlist and have a zero but then we'd
like to really start to get into the
details of of of of what the reality is
about having service providers
connecting with clients and and so that
so that's kind of missing in there and I
don't know if it's worth opening the
minutes up again but I just I don't want
to lose track of the fact that we
have been requesting details
it's no no problem opening them back up
again
um just wouldn't print them out before
the the meeting of course so
um how does how do you want me to work
that continuing conversation about uh
fully funded I think we could just keep
it simple and add a second pull it under
DD waitlist I mean this is me it's the
Chairman's call but I I I I think it
would be adequate to just say that
um the uh the the the the the the that
the committee continues to voice
interest in receiving
details on
the actual wait list you could actually
say funded positions versus filters yeah
no I I don't I don't I don't I don't
know if it's as clear as it was whether
they're funded or filled but I I said I
said versus yeah we know what fun it is
just because we funded them doesn't mean
that there's a person actually
delivering these Services because we've
got a provider from and that's kind of
the rub I thought that was what your
well that that is a waypoint to where
I'm going yes ma'am I I just am also
hoping that eventually we get beyond the
the whether or not we have the case
managers working the cases but the
actually get to the provider level
so like let's say you've got somebody on
the DD waitlist that needs five services
and two of them are being met but the
other three are not because the humans
don't exist uh in that area I I I would
hope that we're we're trying to
aggregate that kind of data so that we
can get a view that's that's really
where I'm going
but if you just made that a bullet I I'd
be happy to just defer how you write
that to you and we can still approve
these minutes with that change I I think
it funded but however the court feels
most comfortable is running in Dallas
so I'd like to move that we accept the
minutes with the contingent upon the
clerk writing and trusting the clerk to
make sense out of what was just said
yeah
all in favor
aye aye opposed
now um and they children up my spine
recently when I learned that there was
in fact a standing subcommittee on
um Alzheimer's disease it's a bigger
title than that that that is out of this
committee and I've been chairman for
three years and I never heard of it and
sometimes things go into a bands and we
can always blame either the cat or kovid
when something goes wrong so since then
I've been brought up to speed and I
would just like about oh maybe five
minutes to get before all of us what
this special subcommittee is about the
amendment that's been produced and where
we go from there so we'll certain
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair I think the thing that stimulated
the observation that we were supposed to
have this subcommittee and and it did
not exist was an initial initiative and
hp2 by Senator avard working with a
couple of lobbyists that are with us
today
Tom and Jess and they have really great
last names if I would remember them but
but so so they have been supporting an
initiative to write an hb2 item saying
that we wanted to invest a half a
million dollars in the coming budget
cycle so that we could develop a public
awareness campaign specifically to help
with Alzheimer's and other memory
related issues and to take it through
Miss Hardy's department and um in the in
a branch related to Wendy Altman's
elderly Affairs I'm not getting the
title exactly right but
but so this is a new initiative the
department is recognized the need to
develop some materials to help the
public understand the importance of
things like going and getting a the
Medicare
testing going through the Medicare
testing program to to start to Benchmark
and evaluate changes in cognitive
abilities and other things and their
half a million dollar appropriation and
in their effort to find stakeholders to
coordinate this public awareness
campaign with they wanted to interact
with the subcommittee that's supposed to
be part of this oversight committee and
that's what the chairman is referring to
a subcommittee that that has not been
appointed in in the recent memory so
um so it would be my recommendation that
the chair consider
at least doing a a partial
delegation and an establishment
re-establishment of this subcommittee
just so that there's at least a connect
point for the hb2 item and the
stakeholders so that there's someone who
pick up the phone from oversight
the chairman has actually begun that and
going back to chapter 126 Dash a colon
15 Dash small a the subcommittee on
Alzheimer's disease and other related
dementia we have all of these wonderful
people who are supposed to be appointed
and uh
Argyle Miss escaland
has been on this and contacting people
and making recommendations and uh wow so
thank you would you would you folks like
to come on up and say a few words
because we've got this chapter 126 uh I
think you all should have one
well they're coming up I will say but I
was the immediate fast chair before you
and I didn't know about it either
so that gives us five years of
restriction wow
well thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Tom prasall from
Demers and praisal we represent the
Alzheimer's Association my name is
Jessica escalind I'm the senior public
policy manager for the Alzheimer's
association's New Hampshire chapter
and so this initiative as was discussed
uh was brought forward it was brought to
my attention by Tom that this existed in
statute and it seemed I know that
previous legislation had come through
that subcommittee that was able to
really do a deep dive and take a look at
these issues and had come up with some
really positive policy in the past due
to some vacancies and staff turnover in
my position as well as then subsequently
coveted it sounds like as the chair said
this was sort of held in advance and
this is something that we're eager to
revive to look at this issue that's
becoming even more prevalent of an issue
here in New Hampshire so
um happy to be a resource help organize
as we discussed in any way that is that
is helpful but that's really what we're
looking to do and as representative
Edwards said they are named as a
stakeholder in that language in House
Bill 2 just to have
um more oversight more engagement with
the legislature and folks charged with
looking at these issues I do have a
question in that a memo to me of the
22nd of February on Senate Bill 234 FNA
an act directing the Department of
Health and Human Services to develop the
campaign and then the aforementioned
chapter law about the subcommittee
is it true does anyone know has that
Senate Bill 234 been folded into the
trailer bill
it has it has yeah okay so um not in its
original version we had worked with
representative Edwards I know he had
shared language that we had arrived at
uh through discussion with him and with
the great Folks at HHS to get to
language that um everyone was
comfortable with so it maintains the
original Spirit of the bill but with
much more specifics and adding that the
appropriation would since sunset in 25.
so the program part of it is in the
trailer bill but the establishment of
the commission is already in law correct
so you have been doing due diligence to
find these various representatives to
fill all these slots yes uh that you
really appreciates that because I do
that job sometimes and uh thank you also
for our purposes
um Pat long representative Pat long had
chaired this at one point and I would
like to give him first right of refusal
if he'd like to pick this up and run
with it again he's got the experience uh
we're not bringing Don LeBron out of
retirement to do it so I think um
representative Edwards would be excuse
me representative long would be
wonderful and we'll be in touch with him
and go from there anything else before
we move on I I would I would just say
that if for whatever reason
representative long uh is not interested
in doing it I'd be happy to to be the
rep I've now gotten dirty enough with
the issue that I I would know kind of
where we should go well that's what I
thought as soon as you first sent me
that
draft
Senate thing that
yeah okay sure if I can just make a
quick comment about some of the work uh
the past work that the permanent
subcommittee has done it's developed a
state plan for the state for Alzheimer's
and Dementia training they worked on
creating a silver alert program for if
someone wanders or is missing and they
also worked on language to create some
dementia training
um do you have
that in your possession somehow I can
find their legislation it's legislation
that has come through and passed uh if
you if you've got that those documents
would be helpful at least for the chair
to have that in the folder on this and
if it's electronic you could send it to
all of us and those of us who wish to
could read it it's just the way getting
up to speed absolutely thank you so much
representative Weber great deal of
discussion in one term about a bill that
was uh training on Dementia or Personnel
at nursing homes and my recollection was
that the discussion
was not so much with respect to the
professionals who worked at nursing
homes but having the the rest of the
Personnel understand the different ways
that people with dementia need to be
related to and so there's a lot of
discussion about whether the brownish
people had to be trained or what the
books had to be trained so but but is
that the one that was one of the the
bills that kind of came out of this uh
permanent subcommittee and it looks like
we have to file legislation by September
this fall one week in September some of
us voted for two but
so if we can have this soon or not later
because if there is more legislation
that maybe needs to be forthcoming we
want to hit the ground on that by that
date representative Merchant thank you
Mr
I think this is a good step going
forward what I find missing is that drug
therapy is a second part of trading
Alzheimer's
yet there's no pharmacists on this
Commission
so the commission was draft uh
established back in 2014 when I don't
I'm still a pharmacist on the commission
yeah well if you look so how would you
legislative
put it there thank you
I mean that's the only way you can
change this because thank you but as
they meet if you know anyone that would
like to participate obviously it's open
to the public and their input would be
invaluable I may know one
some Mr chair representative Edwards
since the topic was open on potential
legislative future of uh section 126
a15a uh thinking that this hasn't
operated in five years and the
legislature is still functioning uh I
I'd be thinking that we should scale
this back or be thinking about
eliminating it but for the fact that it
has an apparent task in the near future
relative to helping with the particular
public awareness campaign and and I I'd
be thinking more about legislation that
would sunset this and to expand it but I
would suggest to any of us because we do
need to move on I would suggest that
anybody who has any ideas on how to
change the law as it exists by adding or
taking away you Talk Amongst various
people who have some history with this
representative long whomever the
associations and informally Talk Amongst
yourselves because coming back to
September we don't have much time if we
want to do something
representative King this is a I hope
this is a really easy one can you just
spell your names for the minutes
my last name is price all p-r-a-s-o-l
-s-o-l
thank you and escalindi's e-s-k-e
-l-a-n-d
it was a very easy question thank you we
we also do have another meeting on the
fourth Friday of June before we go into
summer Hiatus so if people want to be
busy and talk amongst themselves we
could put that into the agenda going
forward over the summer we can have a
first bite of that rep I I always call
you representative Williams and I mean
no disrespect
so thank you thank you so much
um we squoze this one in because it
looked sudden and topical and now we
have our monthly time with the
commissioner or time with Lori and this
time we recognize interim commissioner
foreign
good afternoon thank you that was stuff
up here I know
so I thought I would
shape my updates for you today around
um our mission zero some of you may or
may not know that as of this morning
well it is mental health awareness month
or month of May and this morning the
department has announced its uh Mission
zero which basically is our effort to
reduce the Ed wait list of boarding and
bring that number down to zero the team
the behavioral team at the department
including myself has been working
steadfast over the last several months
to really analyze the factors that it
would take to do that and there were
three key drivers that I will shape my
updates around and those drivers are the
front door issues they're inpatient
Supply and coordination issues and
backdoor issues and we may have heard
some of these in terms of the front door
issues
sure inpatient Supply and coordination
services and I'll go through each one of
them but in terms of the front door
you've heard me here and others front
door is the most obvious where do people
go when they're in terms of distress and
need that high level of care needing
some designated receiving facility beds
commonly called drf beds so we've had a
contract with solution Health we're
going to be building a hospital with a
total of 120 Dr foot beds that's going
to be coming online at the I think end
of 25 beginning of 26th we have
Dartmouth Health that we've contracted
with for five additional drf beds that
should come online I Believe by the end
of this calendar year beginning up next
we have New Hampshire hospital has 31
beds offline but however Wednesday at
Council we have a contract passed to
finally begin the renovation of E and F
unit as we know it today enf unit was
significantly impacted by flooding as
well because that's just the way it goes
with good luck or bad luck and so we not
only do we have to renovate we have to
mitigate I was in the facility last week
touring and I was actually quite taken
aback by the level of water damage
needless to say there's a lot of work to
be done there and it is beginning so
that is great news and we're looking for
that to come online at the end of this
calendar year
foreign
e slash F so e so a b c d e we name our
units like the letter of the alphabet
yeah so EF yep that's an easy one I can
spell that one
so that would be just that's how we
coordinate them
that's New Hampshire Hospital enf unit
yes and there's been a lot of discussion
about those beds being offline and part
of it uh has been this renovation that
will finally happen which is wonderful
um being bringing some beds that will
address some of our front door issues
and we are also bringing online services
that are called crisis stabilization
centers so those are going to be centers
in the community related with our
community mental health centers that
will basically be places for people to
go other than the emergency room they
will see people up to 23 hours it's not
a it's not a bed per se but it is a
crisis stabilization where folks can get
services and if they need continued
Services after that for Ed they can and
then if not they may need a lesser level
of care so we're really focusing in on
the front door but as we all know it's
not just the front door it's also the
back door I'm just going to skip to the
back door first before I get to
inpatient Supply so when we think about
all the folks that we have currently and
I'll just talk about New Hampshire
hospital we have patients there
currently today that don't need that
level of care and they have nowhere to
go to so now we have
folks that may have stabilized and don't
have transitional housing Supportive
Housing or step-down care so the
department is focusing on adding
traditional transitional housing beds
step down care as well as landlord
incentives programs so the department
will be focusing on that legislatively
budget wise it's going to take us a
little bit to do that but that's what
we're putting and focusing the money and
the attention to be able to not only
take care of the front end but the back
end there's also the inpatient Supply
and coordination issues so as we know
today there are we have a level of
systems of care so we in the children's
system of care we have five levels one
through five and then we have the
hospital
starting next Friday on May 26th we will
have our first level five service called
the psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility that's the
p-r-tf psychiatric Residential Treatment
Facility first in New Hampshire it's
pretty groundbreaking it's pretty
exciting I believe all of you will be
invited to that for it for next week for
next Friday at Hampstead Hospital I've
seen it you've seen it you may have
heard it you've heard of it so that's
very exciting for us that's going to be
serving children serving ages 5 to 21
and those will be the kids that maybe
don't need that acute level of care and
really you know maybe struggling to stay
in a successfully finish treatment in a
lower level of care so just because
you're in five doesn't mean you go four
three two one you could be five and step
home you could be five and maybe you
step down to four and then go home and
the event that you're five and you need
additional you can be assessed and
potentially receive those Services right
at New Hampshire hospital for the acute
level of care we are also I've got a
grant from samsa for a certified
community behavioral health clinics
there'll be two pilots this year if
those go well those will be stood up
throughout the state so that's basically
serving populations that have
co-occurring issues of substance use
disorder as well as mental health issues
in addition to that we have what we call
care coordination so we're targeting
care coordination positions to assist
with bed management so I will share with
you that today as of today we have 30
people on our wait list
today we have 25 drf open beds in the
system that are not New Hampshire
hospital beds so I'll just say that we
have 25 open beds that are not New
Hampshire hospital so this is a real
problem those beds are in hospitals
right now and if you look at our website
you will be able to see who those
facilities are that have open beds we
have 25 people 25 beds 30 people we
could have a wait list of five today so
when we talk about Mission zero it's
really important I just want to make the
point that it takes all of the system to
to be able to address that
oh I'm sorry you are speaking so fast
and I'm just hoping that maybe you have
this written down or notes that you
could send to us or a handout or
something sure just because I can't
write this fast and it's all really in
for interesting information that I
suspect our clerk is probably feeling so
the good news is that it's we did a
press release it's on our website but
much of what I'm sharing with you right
now today so we can get you that written
statement and I will link that try to
speak slower I don't mind your speaking
fast I just can't write that fast sure
understand if the information is
elsewhere my ears are fine if my end
doesn't keep up sure so I so I just the
point I want to make when we think about
care coordinator positions it's really
somebody at that macro level being able
to look at what are all the resources in
the system State and not State and how
are they being utilized so our care
coordination positions if we're able to
get this approved would be having
um social workers in RNs being able to
do that oversight and then working in
calling hospitals and saying we have
patients can we get patients in and
moving patients around so that those
beds are being used and people aren't
staying in the system longer than they
need to representative Edwards I'm I'm
afraid you we may fast forward through
uh an important thing you just said I
that needs some detail you you said we
have 25 drf beds that are open we have
30 patients competing for those 25 beds
but there sounds to be seems to be a
problem in getting those any of those 30
placed
did I hear that wrong or is there a
reason why we can't take those 30 and
move some of them it currently has no
authority to force any of those
hospitals to take patients off of the Ed
so so short of force what is the issue
what's the problem why why they want to
accept patients we have patients it
sounds like it's win-win
I'm not quite sure exactly what the
roadblock is but it's not a new
roadblock and I think from our
perspective we're looking at it or do we
not have good care coordination I mean
those the hospitals report to us what
open beds they have it goes on our
website we ask them to to take them why
the reasons they can't take them I can't
answer that
unfortunately I don't see Paul I'm in a
hand either here today
I'm sorry
okay
can you answer that
could you speak to that on behalf of
hospitals there's there's a mic at the
end of the table if you just want to use
good afternoon for the record Kathy
Bazaar with unberg Executive Vice
President New Hampshire Hospital
Association could you say your name
again slowly for my clerk who listens
well and writes well but may need a
little help Kathy with a K Bizarro B's
and boy i z a r r o
one more time
b-i-z-a-r-r-o
thank you thank you and you are with the
New Hampshire Hospital Association as
what again I'm the Executive Vice
President exec VP okay yeah
so thank you for the question
um yes there are
hospitals that do have designated
receiving facilities throughout the
state
um they may have some beds that are
unfilled because they also have staffing
issues just like New Hampshire hospital
does as well
I need to look at the Department's
website to understand their definition
of open beds because there is an ability
for the hospitals to
the hospital has the ability the
hospital also fills some of those drf
beds with voluntary patients which I
think sometimes fills the beds as well
not with drf patients
um that is potentially possible but
um that would mean that that bed is not
full
so I guess we need to understand from
the Department's perspective what they
consider to be open beds versus
available beds so I would love to have
that conversation with the department so
we can clear up that distinction okay
that's what we do here is we try to make
everybody get absolutely okay good we'll
do that thank you so much thank you Mr
chair
representative Merchant
out of curiosity
um in regards to the hospitals with
these open beds or available beds
is there certain hospitals it seems to
be more prevalent time at the time or is
it sort of a random
so I'm trying to get to are there
certain hospitals that are showing up on
that calendar so to speak
time and time again or is it basically
at that point in time sort of a random
selection between the hospitals within
the state sure I'd have to go back and
analyze that data look to see if they're
ones that were trending a certain way
but not every hospital in the state has
drf beds we do have certain hospitals
that have beds certain number of beds
and they are supposed to be taking
involuntary patients just like New
Hampshire hospital the the data would be
helpful thank you yes thank you
so
representative Edwards okay thank you so
Madam commissioner I I uh I I hope that
you have a very productive conversation
and uh with the hospital Association and
if you if you guys in the process of
talking this through end up needing some
some help you know uh please you know
let us know you know you could let me
know you could let the chair know but um
I think we need an all hands on deck
approach and I think you do too on
getting this ER boarding issue under
control and and so we we can't we can't
help you if we don't know what the
problems are and so we're very open to
that and and I would encourage the
hospital Association to to be part of
the team you know in Afghanistan we said
one team one fight even though we were
from all the NATO countries and all the
the tribes in Afghanistan we still
unified to do one thing and so the one
thing we have to unify to do I think is
to get this ER boarding thing down to
zero so I I just I just would like us to
have that Focus
thank you I I will completely support
that it is an all hands on deck effort
it cannot just be the state
uh the state can't one can't move nimbly
but it doesn't have the resources we
have to work with all of our partners so
when we look at these positions that I'm
talking about the care coordinator
positions they would be doing just that
they would be calling and working with
the hospitals and figuring out where are
the barriers where are the pinch points
why why aren't these beds getting filled
so it's Our intention to be able to put
that into place to have better care
coordination Court care coordination and
to be able to have some movement in the
system and not have people waiting in
EDS I think we all want the same thing
at the end of the day so I just share
that my update in terms of the
department puts forth its commitment
towards Mission zero to do its best to
reduce uh Ed boarding but we cannot do
it alone um I will just reiterate that
so when we get to you know things like
landlord incentive programs we are going
to need some help legislatively for sure
our transitional housing beds um you
know we see contracts going through if I
could just continue with some of my
update in segwaying into New Hampshire
hospital I talked about the renovation
Nation we're also recruiting recruitment
efforts continue and will intensify so
as we near the date and date of the
renovation that we're able to bring beds
online as soon as possible but in
addition to New Hampshire hospital we
also have a forensic hospital that is
going to be built on top of or beside I
should say New Hampshire hospital so
that contract just received approval
this morning at fiscal for a little bit
of extra money because all costs have
gone up
since we started our bid process but Das
assures me that the cost difference
that's that it has gone up is still
within a contingency that's somewhat
reasonable compared to other projects so
I remain hopeful that we will now still
have enough money to break ground we
have a contractor for construction
selected and that work is about to begin
so that's pretty exciting um it's been a
long road to get there and two one other
thing is just construction I I know I
think I should get a hard hat for my job
here the site selection for the new
Youth Development Center the evaluation
site report was released last month and
some of you may be familiar with that we
compared three sites we had an outside
party do the three sites so we looked at
things like the size of the site the
ability for shared services access
utilities surrounding environment
proximity to population centers and
external services so out of the three
that we looked at
Hampstead was the clear winner in terms
of points that it came in the quality of
the neighbors really nailed it we didn't
hear that yeah that was that was an
unofficial assessment
so uh we we are um we are currently
waiting for the uh legislatively there's
an impact commission that committee that
is required to start we're waiting for
that to start and we will engage with
the town and answer all the questions
that we need to let me comment I was
privileged to be at that meeting and uh
with the the professionals hired to
examine the sites you know people from
outside the state this is what they do
for for a living and so on and I was
very impressed with how thorough they
went through evaluating they didn't just
grab something for God knows what
reasons they they really did their job
well
um the only thing we lack is a subway
stop outside the building you know
transportation is difficult in South
Rockingham County but uh other than that
yeah they did a great job if you're
interested in seeing the report it is on
our website if you would like to look at
that so I know I've taken up a lot of
time with my my update today however I
know you did ask me to bring director
Buxton and now he's so much that he's
his own item he's not part of my update
um so I do want to point out that when
director Buxton comes up we also have
Stephanie Locke who is our director of
emergency preparedness for the
department and she works in public
health uh as part of the Department of
healthy human services and is connected
to the work that hsam will be doing
so if you don't have any further
questions for me do we have any further
questions representative McDonald
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
commissioner I just wanted to clarify at
the beginning you said Mission zero and
the goal was to reduce a certain type of
wait list was it the New Hampshire
hospital bed wait list the emergency
emergency department wait list okay
thank you
representative Edwards
so I think technically it's not an
emergency department wait list it's the
boarding issue within the emergency
rooms there's all different ways to say
it but yeah Sue could say they eat
people say the Ed wait list yeah I'm
easily confused I just didn't want to
misunderstand so I have two questions Mr
chair one is a big one one's a little
one
um uh so ultimately who is the one
person in charge of mission zero who is
your one accountable leader in the
department
uh one accountable leader would be me
but you surely must delegate you can't
do everything yourself I have a
behavioral health team that is on this
that can is comprised of um our
associate commissioner hand and our
Katya Fox and Ellen Lapointe so Katya
Fox is the director of our Behavioral
Health and Ellen Lapointe is the CEO of
New Hampshire hospital that is the core
team working on this it's a team but
who's in charge
I I'm sorry I'm being obsessive because
I I I it's not a simple answer for me to
say who's in charge it would depend on
what the issue or who has decision
making Authority on that we all do but
uh Marissa hen would be at the helm of
that okay and then this is a detailed
question you probably don't know you
were talking about uh quite a a new
23-hour crisis stabilization uh
capability and I'm just curious if uh
part of coordinating that included
making sure that we had a billing
approach to fund it is is there are
there any issues with having there be a
funding source for the uh crisis
stabilization the 20th I believe there
is a funding source for that I think
it's a contracted service
with the Department oh okay because it's
part of the same it sounded new to me so
I didn't know if there was a billing
code whether it was a contract or you
know no money no Mission so I'm just
curious it is a new service that we're
rolling out it's been in the making of
development for a while
um but they are funded
okay thank you
see no further questions thank you for
your monthly update thank you see you at
and now we do call uh forward Mr Robert
Buxton and Stephanie Locke and this is a
kind of pandemic after action report
that representative Edwards encouraged
us to hear about uh
it's always a good idea I do this in the
facility that I'm in charge of after an
event whether you made a lot of mistakes
so you had a great number of successes
or somewhere in the middle review see
what you did what would you do
differently what would you do the same
where do we go from here because there
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee
foreign
okay so good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee uh Robert
Buxton I have the privilege of being the
director of the division of Homeland
Security emergency management for the
State of New Hampshire I'm also joined
today by our new assistant director uh
Megan Hoskins who's behind me uh and she
is going to be the project manager uh
for this project and with me today also
is Stephanie Locke good afternoon
Stephanie Locke I serve as the bureau
chiefer director of the Department's
Bureau of emergency preparedness
response and Recovery which we
affectionately call Eber because the
so Mr chairman I'm happy to report at
the March 8 2023 meeting the executive
Council approved a contract with a
company named Title Basin Title Basin is
based out of Alexandria Virginia there
are comprehensive all hazards Emergency
Management Company uh focusing on
preparedness response recovery and
mitigation services and they have been
awarded a contract to conduct a
after-action review of the state of New
Hampshire's covid-19 response the
document will serve as a record of the
state of New Hampshire's story during
the covid-19 pandemic and in regards to
the events processes including successes
and areas of improvement and solutions
are a requirement of the RFP they will
focus on the preparedness and response
spanning from January 2020 to June 2021.
however there will be a summary of
details that are outside of that area as
we're aware of the public health
emergency just ended on May 11th so
it'll be a spillover into additional
they have proposed and we've accepted a
four-phase approach to this review on
phase one is the initiation and the
project will go from May 2023 to June
2024. uh the second phase of this will
be data collection and this will be
interview surveys and documentation
review uh During the period that we
discussed and that will take place from
May of 2023 to October 2023. the third
phase of the project will be the AAR and
Improvement Planning Development so this
will be the spot where they review the
data identify Gap analysis and identify
process Improvement and that will take
place from September of 2023 to June
2024 with additional interviews and data
collection and clarifications taking
place
the fourth phase of the project will be
presentation in the final after action
review and Improvement plan to the state
of New Hampshire and that is due in June
of 2024.
um
foreign
the work is obviously that of a project
team and we have approached the team uh
an inclusive of Homeland Security
emergency management the Department of
Health and Human Services the executive
branch and the National Guard who is
part of the process
for implementing and coordinating the
response to covet 19. the project team
will meet weekly virtually with Title
Basin and they will continue to work and
conduct their process throughout the
focuses of preparedness focus is a
barrier that they will they will dial in
on they'll review event planning
processes review plans created prior to
the pandemic and how they were utilized
or not utilized response structures and
how it impacted the overall event
efficiencies and how the can how to
continually continuity of operations
approach to the continually support the
response and preparedness portions of
response Focus areas will work in those
areas that are highlighted in the slide
with concentration looking at the
unified command post and the unified
command approach to the incident
communication with both local state and
private part sector partners
uh the establishment of the supply chain
that was so critical to the overall
response community and the community to
support Public Health efforts with the
hospitals nursing homes schools and
areas of note will be specifics to
looking at the logistical portion of the
distribution of uh excuse me this could
be a brain cramp at the end of a busy
week I'm trying to see how your talk
coordinates with the order of the slides
I'm on the area of notes if you look at
the top of the slide and I have bullets
I I didn't necessarily feel the need to
read each slide to you no but it but I
do and it means I'm skipping all over
the place I'm not paying attention so if
you look at area notes area notes area
of notes on slide seven slide seven
unnumbered okay yeah
so we're looking at the logistical
plants surrounding protective clothing
where the supplies where to find
supplies vaccination distribution
activation and Staffing the logistical
problems and moving supplies around the
state uh and pointing out the efforts
regarding Staffing Emergency Operations
Center on a 24-hour basis how the two on
one system worked working with suppliers
unemployment and other staff and
volunteer volunteers to mobilize and
address the response
if you look at the goals of the program
next slide page eight
these are things that we highlighted in
the initial kickoff meeting make sure
the plan is simple or the report is
simple and easy to understand make sure
it serves as a guide for plans of
disasters moving forward and base the
plan and in which response is better
for next Crisis structural processes and
the state's response can be employed
again if another crisis is created or
happens the governor was very specific
that he wanted to see this be this after
action be a simple process for us to
pull off the shelf and Implement again
in the need of crisis and serve as a
I'm certainly open to any questions you
might have or anything you'd like me to
review
commission chair
representative Edwards
this this is something I have a decent
amount of background in uh similar stuff
and and so so I'd like to just if I may
have kind of a little bit of a
conversation yeah take some time without
asking for uh oh okay so uh it it sounds
like the the plan for what you're going
to do with this after action is already
embedded in a contract that's signed
correct
so
um I think
my reaction to that is that it's
disappointing because I've been asking
about this for a year and not that I
have such a high opinion of my
experience but as I look at this I have
some negative reactions
the on the areas of note under Logistics
PPE where to find supplies this is sort
of the classic military problem that we
always prepare to fight the last war
this area of note
it seems to me to be exactly in that
vein that we're expecting the next
Crisis to look like this crisis and uh
and and I and I think that sort of
biases this and and in a way in which we
we needed to take a look at some other
issues like like what other issues
I would say under areas of note and I
don't even know why I'm saying this now
since this is a contract but uh but it
would be great if there were some
flexibility in here because of the areas
of note
I would think that based on what we've
learned from the CDC in the past year we
ought to have and we knew at the time
that we needed to do a better job of
vetting and validating the Strategic
guidance that we were getting from the
federal government and that we needed to
vet their top-down guidance internally a
little bit and and with that sort of
validation of strategy and top-down
guidance we needed to do a much better
job of sharing a reality-based policy
set of policy decisions with the public
one of the big disconnects in the in the
whole response that this setup will not
touch is
the extent to which we're interacting
with Federal authorities
translating and validating it to New
Hampshire and communicating with our
citizens so that they better understand
what we're doing to them
to a lot of people it felt like we were
doing something to them instead of with
them and for them and and it just feels
to me that the areas of note maybe
should have picked picked up on that a
little bit
and I know that wasn't in the form of
the question but um but but if I may I'd
like to continue
um let me put something in edgewise
which I think maybe picks up on that to
what degree can this committee
meet with the company that has been
hired to input to them or
have they been hired and they're now
turned loose
no the committee was the company was
hired and contracted with hsem to
conduct this review I would have to
check the RFP to see what the overall
engagement with this committee would be
I don't recall from the RFP if there was
a direct call out for this group or not
so that's the follow-up I might have to
take away my follow-up is it doesn't
necessarily have to be this group yeah
but this sounds like the same top-down
we know best
kind of stuff that has angered a lot of
people in the legislature
representative Edwards so thank you Mr
chair
um and I'm so sorry I I I spent a career
in the Army doing this sort of thing and
so I I feel like I have some experience
here on on the page where you've got
response Focus areas
there's a compliance and decision-making
bubble and and that's that's kind of
what I suggested could be an area of
validation of the Strategic top-down
guidance is is uh is is the decision
making around that and how those
decisions were made I don't know what
the details are in that bubble but it
may be that within the the contract
that's already in place that that bubble
could be further developed and then on
the three bubbles that are sort of side
by side here on that same page where it
goes Communications information sharing
situational awareness public information
um this comes back to the other area of
emphasis which is sharing the
reality-based policies that are being
developed uh with the public I I don't I
I perceive that if a good AAR would
reveal that we could do a better job of
communicating to the public while why we
are implementing certain certain
policies and limiting and curtailing
certain freedoms uh so that people
understood what was happening and why
um and so I would I would just point out
that
um that there there's a significant
amount of communication that would be
needed I think with the legislature
particularly around superseding and
establishing emergency orders because
that's a suspension of our form of
government when we enter into that sort
of emergency Authority and and and I I
believe that we really ought to take a
serious look in the same they are at
how the political body of the state
interacted with each other to make sure
that the public had their their rights
preserved and um and and were part of of
our comprehensive dealing with the
crisis so
um so I would I would have wanted to
have participated in drafting the RFP or
at least put some feedback in there I'm
really concerned that this thing's
already been let and uh and we're going
to get an expensive document that
creates a new plan hoping that the past
crisis happens exactly like it did so
that we can deal with it rather than
building on a set of principles so that
we know how to react as uh as a as an
organized society and not not just a
top-down control structure and then and
that's and that's and to make that a
question so what do you think of all of
that
so a little bit about me as a person
um I did not draft the RFP that is
before you today uh this is a an
inherited project but uh for those of
you that don't know my history I spent
30 years as a municipal Public Service
employee so as a fire chief Emergency
Management director and a public health
officer in a community in the southern
part of the state so I was inheriting
all of those things as we were
developing the plan and flying the plane
as we're building at the same time I
would tell you looking at the areas that
you pointed out that was going to be my
exact point that I believe that when you
look at the the decision-making
processes and all those things that
would be an expectation that I would
have that we would be examining how
those things got done so that is I
believe part of the AAR will be reviewed
is what that decision-making process
looked like and how that was developed
so I bring a little bit different of a
spin today than may have originally been
attended uh when it was put together so
I hear those things that you're saying
thank you and I uh hearing that I'm
somewhat more reassured by the issue of
local knowledge but
um I and I think you're carrying hearing
some Flack and some frustration from
this committee about several other
projects where there was a company
brought in from away who have told us
how to do things and they have had
minimal input from the people whose
lives are affected by it and so I kind
of wanted to put what I think to build
on what both Representatives Pearson and
Edwards are saying
making a plea for local input
and for again working for I think one of
the things that we're all talking about
is buy-in from the community and that's
Consulting the community and informing
the community and making the community
feel that they are a part of the
solution as well as just being told what
to do because once they understand why
they're being asked to do something
difficult my experience of granite
Staters is they rally around and they're
magnificent and you know I'm thinking
about the people who were making masks
and sewing lab coats because we didn't
have any and there we are using 18 you
know 1910 technology for a 20th century
problem so I I do hope that it will be
communicated very clearly to Title Basin
that some of the data collection needs
to be the experiences of local people
and what they were dealing with and not
just the experiences necessarily of
representative Merchant next and then
representative Edwards thank you thank
you Mr I looked at the Timeline which is
what will be the process to provide this
committee
periodic updates as we go from phase one
great question and I would I'm going to
Turf that one right over to the
commissioner of DHHS and ask for what
the reporting requirement may be I'm
issue the commissioner I think is left
I'm sorry so we would have to work that
out with the with the agency to see what
they want for a reporting mechanism
moving forward uh through the contract
uh the phases uh don't necessarily uh
call for report outs so we can develop
that as we move forward that's thank you
but that would be in the RFP what I'm
asking is not what's in the IRP what the
department does as far as reporting back
so I'm sitting on this project committee
as well and so I am keep
the commissioner informed and I'm happy
to work with her to make sure that we
have a Cadence of updates for this
committee throughout the process
representative Edwards thank you Mr
chair
um so since this contract has been
signed there should be something that
I've called in the past a statement of
work the the section c and the federal
government I don't know what it is in
state government but the there's very
specific deliverables uh could could we
get a copy a digitally sent to us of
what the statement of work is for this
contract yeah absolutely we can get you
a copy of the entire contract and call
that else no no no no no you just want
that one second I want the section that
says we can certainly get that to you
right right I don't want to go to law
school to read the boilerplate I just
want to know what the okay all right
thank you
I was one of
30 legislators that spent four days
I won't say where it was in Atlanta I
mean I won't say what the organization
was but it's based in Atlanta
and when we finally got a chance to
respond
from the most Progressive to the most
Arch conservative members of the group
we were angry
not necessarily at some of the decisions
that were made in an emergency in real
time
but the tenure
we were angry at the attitude I don't
want to be angry here
I want
stakeholders and I understand it's
sometimes difficult to work on a project
and have a discussion when you have too
many other folks wanting to jump in
right away I get that I share things I
know how that feels but on the other
hand as things are released at the end
I want to say this was a collaborative
effort and while I don't agree with
everything here I agree with the process
I felt listens to I felt lots of people
were listened to that's what I want to
be able to say
as much as I like the conclusions so
if I could add one thing at least one of
the things that we did add during the
initial conversation with them was
specific to your comment regarding
surveying of the local municipalities
and and getting a survey out the local
level make sure we have that information
coming so that that process to reaching
down and getting down to the local level
is already underway
but I will say positively that during
the pandemic there was something that
was coming down from on high and I
called up and since I've known that
person I was in Health and Human
Services committee for six years still
keep up with that some of the folks
um I picked up the phone called somebody
and said
you don't want to do that you really
don't and I gave reasons why and we had
a good conversation and I didn't get
everything I wanted but I got listened
to and taken seriously and not the brush
off and sounds like they were listening
but they weren't and what came out was
responsive and you know that kind of
makes me to some degree a DHHS groupie
so I want to give that part of it too
representative Edwards okay so in terms
of stakeholders uh I I I've had an
opportunity to observe that Civilization
is far more fragile than most Americans
perceive and one of the things that
happened because of the way we were
doing the exact executive orders and and
creating promulgating new restrictions
was creating
um a Bottoms Up
kind of mob attitude
um I I I hate using the word
insurrectionist
um but but there were we we fed into uh
this sort of angst and anger uh and it
had the restrictions been more severe or
more prolonged uh I I don't know I I I
did not like the the social chemistry
that was taking place that could
potentially lead to violence so what so
what I would ask this AAR to do and go
talk to some other shareholders in those
sort of agitator communities like
rebuild New Hampshire has calmed down
quite a bit there's probably some groups
we could get you hooked up with go talk
to the people who were hostile about
what happened to listen to them on on
why they got so spun up so that the next
time we do this we have a little bit of
sensitivity to try to
build those bridges before somebody's
you know goes there's no Bridge here so
you know so so you mentioned
municipalities could be potential
shareholders stakeholders that's great
but I I don't think that's it's it's
necessary but not sufficient I think you
need to reach out and and get into the
communities of hostility and and listen
to them
so
is that possible or or is your
stakeholder sphere already scoped
I think the local municipalities are the
gateway to getting to those groups to be
honest with you it well they're going to
highlight you know you can go and
highlight and watch who's participating
at the local level whether it's at a
board meeting or school board meeting
and highlight those groups and be able
to figure that piece out so let's let us
take a look at that I I hear the message
I hear the ask and let's see what we can
pull together on that I think that your
message is crystal clear today in
regards to what you're looking for for a
stakeholder involvement and I I
appreciate that
other of you any of you familiar with
the book the psychology of pandemics
I'm not read it
I would suggest
um
and as a people Watcher as a people
person over the years
that's something I know a little bit
about is different kinds of people
reacting in different ways under
different stressors
and with a couple of exceptions the
author of this book nailed it in terms
of the pandemic
except it wasn't written during the
pandemic It Was Written two years before
him analyzing the flu epidemic of a
hundred years ago Mars serves all of
those and watching how different people
react to authority figures to
presentations of facts to all kinds of
things and the people in the equation
are as important as where the equipment
can be found and I just suggest this
because
um
I'm part-time CEO of a Medical
Counseling facility and we were ready
for the pandemic not only in terms of
equipment but in terms of doing studies
of our patients how they are likely to
react when the big one hits which we
knew it was about to and because we knew
them and because we thought not just
about having supplies and coordinating
off part of the building and all of
those important things we needed to do
but we did a psychological study of our
patients
so
we were right how they reacted but we
were ready for them so psychology of a
pandemic is an excellent read and will
inform anything this group does
um did I see representative Merchant
thank you Mr Mr Fox I want to say thank
you for what you're doing
um it's not an easy task obviously but
in saying that one of the things I think
a theme here I'm hearing and I would
chime in on this as well
this is well laid out dealing with a
process but one of the key parts of a
process is human beings and I don't see
anything here dealing with the
psychology of what you're trying to get
to because that is underlying all of
this when you get into a pandemic
is trying to understand how the Public's
going to react to certain things what
kind of information we're going to have
to communicate with the public I just
would encourage you folks I know the RFP
has probably even developed and signed
but think about this you go through the
processes how do we engage the public
how do we try to at least understand the
public because ultimately at the end of
the day they're the ones that we need to
take care of but a lot of times they
don't come along willingly they have to
basically be a lot of education and so
forth with us are somewhere along the
way you can in your side notes put that
as a side note please
thank you the author of the
aforementioned book is Stephen with a V
Stephen Taylor and it was published
interestingly
October of 2019.
just before
anyone else
I just want to apologize
Mr chair I want to apologize to our
guests that I was I'm a little spun up
on this issue it's taken me a year of
twisting that and it just Unleashed on
you so I apologize for the bluntness and
directness and it wasn't meant to be
accusatory I it's just accumulated
frustration syndrome
I appreciate you I appreciate your
comments and I don't take it any harm 30
years of dealing with municipal
government I'm sure has built up an
appropriate uh thin thick skin sir yes
sir good good that's what we want thank
okay now developmental Services redesign
implementation status update with
Melissa Hardy and Cindy for Rose
like the kings of each that's right
that's not the same way
I don't know do you know any pharaohs
good afternoon I'm Melissa Hardy I'm the
director for the division of long-term
supports and services
I'm Sandy Pharos bureau chief of Bureau
of Developmental services
thank you for having us this afternoon
to provide a quick update on the routine
house bill 608. I apologize for saying
I'm a groupie but go ahead oh no we like
groupies we'll we'll take you on no
problem
um so I wanted to give a little update I
know we presented last month as well for
an update but
um the biggest thing that's happened
between then and now is we've started
our cohort work as far as bringing the
providers online so we have three
cohorts of about 15 providers in each
cohort that a leader from BDS is leading
one of each of those cohorts
um it started today so we had our
kickoff meetings with the three cohorts
this morning
um and so it's really the shepherd
providers on a smaller level to come on
board with the direct billing process
and answer their questions in a small
group with targeted folks being
available to respond to their questions
representative so we're talking about
the same thing because I have had real
difficulties wrapping my head around
what we're saying when we're saying
providers uh are we talking about Case
Management Services are we talking about
Direct Care Services what which sort of
providers are we talking about and and
if you could equate this with who's
doing the providing now and what we're
shifting to that would be very helpful
for me sure so um before this time all
of the area agencies were our Veterinary
agencies in New Hampshire were really
our primary contact who had contracts
with providers that provided
um you know it could have been day
Services it could be Employment Services
right exactly
um so when when I'm speaking of
providers we are now in direct contact
with those providers that were typically
contracted with the area agencies so
that would be those community-based
organizations that provide services to
folks with developmental disabilities
okay thank you yes
um and so we believe that having these
smaller cohort groups as we're coming
online for for July 1st will provide a
more one-on-one approach
um to be able to answer questions that
they have in troubleshoot in real time
as far as any concerns as it relates to
you know our information system billing
processes enrollment status I'm so we're
excited to report that that kicked off
today uh based on the enrolled providers
that we have
um I don't know if there's anything you
want to get into that Sandy
visitature
representative Merchant to pick up this
point sure thank you
what I'm hearing if I understand it's
correctly following up reps and Weber's
comment the agencies were the ones
coordinating the care before so the way
it flowed was from the Department to the
agency to the provider
correct yes so the department to the
area agency to the provider so now we're
going from the Department directly to
the provider yes and the area agencies
are still involved some of them are
providers as well of these Services
um and they're still a very relevant
role in our in our whole delivery system
as far as intake and eligibility for
people on the waiver providing support
to individuals and families with
developmental disabilities but the real
change is these providers will be able
to directly Bill and not contract with
the area agencies to provide service
thank you
please continue
um so we also are excited to have
um scheduled some more family in-person
um engagements not only in person but
we're also going to do virtual sessions
to engage individuals and families with
disabilities about any concerns or
questions that they may have
um with the 7-1
um rollout but also Beyond so
um really trying to connect to those
people in the community who are actually
receiving the services and having that
direct dialogue with them so we're
planning some in-person meetings in June
we're also having some online
conversations as well as a video that
they can watch as far as you know what
is direct Bill and what does that mean
to me as a family member or an
individual receiving services
foreign
thank you you want that
thank you so much
given the fact that I'm going back to
what talked about before on the provider
and the change from the agency to direct
contract with you over the provider
who's doing the actual care
how is the agency being funded because I
would make the Assumption before when
they're doing the billing they probably
were taking a certain percentage of the
billing to support the agency so are we
going to disrupt the agencies because
they don't have a
a funding mechanism to keep themselves
afloat so we've worked with the area
agencies to develop a Medicaid
administrative rate for those Services
which was funded and we're waiting for
CMS to give us the official stamp of
approval on that methodology but we did
take their costs into consideration in
building that rate with a rate setting
vendor thank you yes
representative Edwards so so I think to
uh to the point that representative
Merchant brings up or Marshawn uh that
that this is an area of concern for the
area agencies because they've adapted to
a particular business model and this is
a transition to a different kind of
business model and it's it it it if you
if you love economics it also interjects
a new component instead of taking a
share of their revenue to help fund
their expenses it's now an admin
administratively uh
an administratively built developed a
fee which gets to be more in a command
and control
kind of environment instead of a free
market and so whether or not that's
going to be adaptable and flexible over
time I think it's just more challenging
because you give up sort of um the
breathing that goes with tying it to
revenues I and and I I think the other
thing that's going on in the economics
of the area agencies that we should know
a little bit about is that there are
additional requirements for some I.T
system development that's not part of
your presentation today but in the one
area agency's disclosure I'm on the
board of one sky so I'm I'm I'm I'm not
advocating I'm just trying to say what
I've learned from that and that is that
they they're spending like ten thousand
dollars a month for their I.T systems in
order to support the requirements of the
department and that's going to go up to
fifteen thousand dollars a month so it's
a doubling of their expenses and and so
um so so there's just a lot of concern
out there amongst the area agencies
whether or not you know they're going to
be viable and and it may be that some of
them need to go away because we don't
need 10 in the future if we can direct
bill but but that's the challenge I
foreign
representative McDonald thank you Mr
chairman uh it's noticed in this week's
calendar but um this week this coming
week um the health and human services
and elderly Affairs committee will be
addressing our retained bills kind of
mapping out the strategy you know in the
anticipation of the Fall deadline and
this obviously is on the list so
um and I've got I've solicited feedback
from committee members to see which
bills they want to work on we've got
about a dozen and uh you know we'll be
sifting through that and planning our
strategy but uh it's it's all very much
thank you for your report and especially
thank you for
your movement in listening to
stakeholders again like there's so many
things at least they want to be listened
to and it sounds like you're making some
good progress that way so thank you for
that thank you okay
you guys aren't done okay
we are unless there's something you want
to discuss well I was hoping done I was
I was hoping that we could ask our
monthly question about the uh the wait
list the real wait list and what kind of
metrics and statistics you can give us
um would representative Jess Edwards
like to ask our monthly question of our
esteemed guests
do you have any new
graphics from data Force
so we generally do the wait list every
quarter so we did it last month I don't
have any updated statistics for this
quarter Mr chair Miss already told me
that last month and I forgot it's a
quarterly report thank you for giving
you yeah
the channel recognizes Olivia May
director of Medicaid Enterprise
development and Dr Sarah Finney Medicaid
dental director and attorney Robert F
Berry general counsel and legislatively
Azan Division of Medicaid services to
you get the whole team today you're
welcome to sit at the end over there and
it's not voidia and you failed
thank you Mr chairman um for the record
uh my name is Robert Berry I'm general
counsel to the division of Medicaid we
have Dr Sarah fenney who's the Medicaid
dental director and we have Olivia May
who is the director of Medicaid
Enterprise
development uh so we'll Begin by
speaking about the goings-ons with the
uh the new dental adult Dental benefit
and then we'll transition to
um some updates on SB 263 which you you
may be aware of
um
[Laughter]
um so yeah we'll talk about that a
little bit it seems a little odd to tell
you guys what's going on with SB 263
because I did watch it yesterday I'm
very very well aware
um but
so without further Ado I'll pass it over
to Dr Finney and director me
good afternoon chair and committee
members it's nice to see you again
we've had a lot of exciting things going
on with the dental benefit
as far as our Network goes we've seen a
slow steady progression of an increase
in providers in the network
as of the the dashboard from May 10th we
are up to 117 providers at this point
one of our priorities is to improve
access for geographic regions that have
limited provider Supply and doing this
through the use of mobile dental clinics
that is one of the key strategy for
supporting access in the identified
regions
these clinics uh have been
ongoing since April 1st there have been
second visits to both Colebrook and
Concord that were very successful not
only did they have uh reappointments
with folks that were seen on April 1st
but they also were able to see some
additional members on the second visits
and basically the way that we're looking
at moving forward is watching our
Network adequacy across the state and
making decisions about where those
mobile events will happen based on where
we have areas that have true need and
we're having more difficulty providing
access with providers in that area just
because there aren't any
um in terms of contract management yes
Excuse me yes representative Weber could
you be a little more specific about
specifically where those areas are
because
um if I'm hearing that a mobile clinic
is going to Concord
um I'm I don't think of it as being a
particularly rural or underserved area
and I know we got into this last time
about whether Washington was an urban
area or not but I just want to know
where it is that you're looking at at
needing to fill in services so we know
it's actually a combination of the
number of providers and the number of
members that are residing in a certain
area there's also certain
um
locations that lend themselves to doing
a mobile service so conquered is a
central location and the facility that
we had available allowed us to not only
have the mobile van itself but an area
to greet the members determine
eligibility and then move them on to
services
so it's it's not one single
criteria that we have for making that
decision it's it's there's many
different
um different pieces that go into the
decision of where the clinics go so so
am I understanding that part of what the
mobile centers are doing is signing up
people not just providing Direct
Services it's correct they're signing up
members it's that you know eligibility
has to be confirmed the day of the
appointment and so you need to have an
area where that can be done with privacy
and
um so you know there's there's a
facility piece of this beside just the
Mobile land itself okay thank you one
would think that a rural area would have
a lot of privacy
Mr representative Edwards so my my
commenter question is is really very
related to what representative Webber
just said and that is that that my issue
has has been that
um uh in division three we had these
nice New Hampshire maps presented to us
with the demographics of of the state
and that there were like five Hot
Pockets of of um where we had
um
disproportionate diversity issues and
five particular areas and so I am just
trying to map what you all tell me
you're doing with what the effect on the
ground is I want to know that we are
proactively monitoring these
traditionally underserved communities
and that were explicitly trying to uh
resolve those
so um we are working on developing maps
to visualize exactly what you describe
what the access looks like in every
region of the state we do have that
information from Northeast Delta Dental
and DentaQuest but it's just not at this
time in a format we felt was ready to
present to this audience but we
anticipate having that in future
meetings so so representative Weber hit
me upside the head with a common sense
stick last time and she said we don't
necessarily need a a heat map like what
I want we could just take a a list of
zip codes in an Excel file or something
so that we could at least begin to
communicate with our colleagues that may
be interested in whether or not their
communities being served so so maybe as
a first step prior to this glorious heat
map thing that I want that we could do
an interim basic data swap we could
absolutely do that and I'll say too that
leading up to April 1st we had a really
strong focus on certain aspects of
network adequacy include including oral
surgeons and we saw a lot of success on
that service type growth there and now
we are shifting to look more at
Geographic areas of need not that we
weren't looking at them before but
I I think the other thing that I would
like to mention is that
um
yes there are definitely certain areas
of the state that for a long period of
time have been underserved and and we
are aware of them we're also watching
how the membership is changing now that
we are past the phe and we're into what
we refer to as the unwind so there are
some changing demographics with our
members at the same time that we're
watching our provider Network grow so
you know we're trying to make these
decisions but also keeping those two
things in mind as we're we're moving
towards those decisions
follow up let me just wrap that up
that's great I suspect you're really
doing the right thing I'm just asking
for you to take us on the ride with you
so that we can understand exactly what's
going on and that we can communicate
there are 400 of us in theory all around
the state and it'd be great if we knew
what was going on in our communities and
so I I hope to share what you're doing
with them as soon as we get the right
data
that would be terrific I would love to
have 400 recruiters across the state
representative King
yeah so a lot of this sounded familiar
from the last meeting and I'm not going
to say this is why Mr Littman didn't
show up today but he we gave him the
right
yeah you still got time
[Music]
so we can follow up on that to get that
to the committee Mr
business
um
if they're if we're uh
I'm sorry yeah I know what all right
he is one of my two favorite pharmacists
in the House of Representatives so I
cannot ignore him representative thank
you Mr representative Merchant one of
these
would you
um somewhere along the way to help me
understand maybe the rest of the
committee as well as we go through the
Medicaid recertification how this is
going to impact this program
um we're really concerned about is
children because what's
as adults as well as children but if
we're going through recertification
is it going to have a bigger impact on
the dental program versus the medical
program or are they basically
independent of each other therefore what
happens on the medical side really
doesn't impact the dental side and the
other way around
um all right there's there's two parts
to my answer
um the children's benefit remains
unchanged and is as it has been in the
past
um
the same I I think the same impact would
be felt for both medical and dental
because
you have to be fully Medicaid eligible
to have either or both so it would move
along the same way
so do we have some initial data I think
when Miss lippen was here before talking
about the number of people covered by
Medicaid that possibly could be coming
off the rolls because of recertification
are we having any kind of information on
the dental side as well as the medical
side
comparable
so we can are you asking for updates on
the results of the unwind so folks who
are being redetermined for their
Medicaid Eligibility and what impact
that has on enrollment yes you said it
very well thank you do we want to share
updates on that I mean we can speak to
it at a high level that's starting in
April or go ahead Rob so I'm prepared to
provide the grid and Advantage numbers
we do have
um access to the other numbers that we
can absolutely provide after this uh
this meeting but for granted advantage
since the unwind began or a continuous
coverage ended back in on April 1st uh
as of uh 5 15 23 so a few days ago the
grand Advantage enrollment was 75 178
individuals and that's a net decrease of
21 337 since the continuous coverage
period ended on April 1st that's for
granted Advantage we do have numbers for
the others but I don't have those
available at the moment but we can get
them pretty easy thank you thank you and
just in case it's not totally clear so
if someone loses Medicaid Eligibility
you know they have their medical I like
to think of the ID cards they have a
medical ID card they have their Dental
benefit ID card if you don't have
Medicaid anymore you don't have either
of those benefits anymore so it would
impact them kind of equally in that way
and part of the concern
with the adults is that when you have a
dental
issue a lot of times it's multiple
procedures that are being done so what
I'm a concern is that we have
individuals to start in the program that
become disqualified
for the reasons for unwinding if you
will and then all of a sudden they lose
the benefit and I'm trying to figure out
this point in time do we have any people
out there that may fall into that Gap
where all of a sudden they have it one
day but they're not going to have the
next day absolutely yeah I think that is
something we also talk about with
Northeast Delta Dental and Dental Quest
are three medical mcos are a bit more
mature at this point in dealing with the
unwind and supporting their members but
that's something we definitely want to
see from the the dental vendor as well
to prevent avoidable disruption in
service as you mentioned
um let's move on to contract management
uh well CMS did approve the contract
they had asked for us to do an amendment
which will occur this fall and merely
what they asked for in that amendment is
to clean up a lot of language to make
sure that our language matches with the
current Managed Care
requirements that CMS has there was
nothing operational about the contract
that was an issue so it really would be
looked at as cleanup
and so we will embark on that in the
fall
in terms of implementation ID cards and
member materials have been distributed
distributed
um in the initial weeks of the program
operations have run smoothly we've had
some small blips which anyone might you
know expect with a program this large
going up as quickly as it did but
everything has been dealt with by
Northeast Delta and DentaQuest in a
quick and efficient manner to make sure
that operations continue the department
weeks meets multiple times each week
with Northeast Delta and DentaQuest and
we address things as they come up and I
see that those meetings will probably go
on for the the near future because we
want to make sure that we stay on top of
the processes and make sure that
um and then you know we've already
discussed heat maps versus Excel
spreadsheets and we will absolutely
Continue to update you and you know take
your feedback on what best serves your
needs to understand our networking
I'd like to know a little bit about how
big Northeast Delta dentist is compared
to DentaQuest in terms of your providers
I think 117 you said right now right I I
um I don't I'm not sure I understand
your question
well you I mean I think dentistry in New
Hampshire I think Northeast Delta
because that's what I know and they gave
me a free meal
um and I I don't know DentaQuest they're
probably good and I'm sure I'll go out
if they invite me but
um those two groups do what okay now I I
understand okay I do too I was getting
there okay
um Northeast Delta Dental really has the
Deep knowledge of the New Hampshire
dentist Network and in their commercial
plans they are represented
um extremely well I believe their uh one
of their commercial plans they have
upwards of 85 percent of New Hampshire
dentists enrolled in their PPO program
less I think they're somewhere around 50
percent so the reason that Delta was
interested in this contract is because
of their knowledge of dentists in the
state
the reason they subcontracted with
DentaQuest is that DentaQuest runs
Dental Medicaid programs in
approximately 30 States across the
country they are the largest Medicaid
administrator in dentistry out there
right now and so Delta felt that the
combination of the Delta experience to
date in state added together with
deniquest experience running Medicaid
programs made for a good partnership
so it's collaborative yes I could not
see the leader of Delta Dental being a
Ruffian and and what Olivia just pointed
out it's one network it's not like these
two entities each have their it is one
single one work
representative this is one of my
favorite topics on a roll one of my
favorite dentists uh probably because
you've never drilled me so hey
um
um I think you meant to imply it but I
just need to hear it in this contract
rewrite it's none of that's affecting
our waivers our waivers are secure no
the policy is secure policy is secure
waivers are secure This truly is little
tweaks of life I just had to hear it all
right and then the second thing are we
starting to get any data on the number
of no-show appointments because that was
a concern with this population and and
there was some brainstorming that was to
take place that probably did take place
on how to mitigate the the no-shows
under the perception that this is a
community that no shows more frequently
than other communities and so what can
you tell us about no shows and what
we're doing and is it a problem and you
know the like okay the the process that
is in place is that um through the
claims adjudication
um missed appointments and late
cancellations are go go through that
adjudication and then a flag goes out to
care management team and calls are
actually placed to those members to say
we noticed that you missed an
appointment we need to talk to you so
that we can work out you know why you
weren't there
um so there is a whole process for that
that is in place
we're only at May 19th so I really don't
have any
um data that I can share or I've even
had the opportunity to look at to see
what the rates of no-shows and and late
cancellations is but that is definitely
something that we're watching
representative Merchant thank you Mr
that's definitely something I'd like to
keep our eye on because on the provider
side if
they don't have a patient in the chair
there's no revenue for that time and my
concern is if this back to
representative Edward's comment this
community has probably hired no-show
rate than the normal community and I'm
really concerned about the dental
providers out there if they're having a
high incident of no shows what that
means to them on their bottom line given
the fact that most likely the
reimbursement rates for Medicaid are
less than what they come from Delta
Dental from commercial side right so I'm
really concerned about this issue of no
show and what that will mean because if
we don't find a way either to backfill
it financially or work with the
providers to minimize that I think we
could have providers pulling out of the
service and the secretly concern
um what I would like to add is that we
also have a transportation piece of this
contract where
um if members uh through the the risk
assessment that happens you know as they
become
um enrolled with deniquest
if Transportation issues are identified
as something that could potentially
create a problem
um they are also responsible for
providing Transportation or mileage
reimbursement so and those the the
transportation and the Care Management
really came about as a response to our
work group where providers were talking
about what are the things that we need
to have in a benefit that would want
make us want to enroll and then also
stay in the program and it wasn't just
reimbursement it was the no-shows and
and transportation and Care Management
follow-up representative thank you Mr I
want to say thank you for the
transportation to try to solve some of
that issue
however when I look at some of the rural
parts of the state it's hard to get
Transportation it's a real issue for
patients even in medical care so again
back the same thing if I understand this
correctly not looking for the heat map
but looking at the zip codes if in the
rural parts of our state we're having a
low provider participation and that's
only going to be more critical that we
have a way to get them to the dental
clinic and I do concern myself when you
get to some of these small towns even
how we're going to get them to point A
to point B from the home if you will to
the dental clinic and that's again back
to the underlying issue of
what that means to the provider right
and that and that also ties back to
where we decide to take mobile clinics
in the future you know that is another
part of of that decision
I heard you speak of the provider's work
group prior to the rollout to identify
things is there a provider work group
that's going to meet periodically to
assess let's say we've been doing this
for a while now
let's talk about it there are actually
two uh different venues for that to
happen
um prior to us even going down this
adventure with the adult benefit we have
had a dental Medicaid advisory committee
that was a joint function of DHHS and
the New Hampshire Dental Society we are
in full swing we have actually gone from
quarterly meetings to monthly meetings
um just so that we can keep on top of
you know provider issues and and
commentary and helping us to assess what
is going on and then built into a
contract with DentaQuest and Northeast
Delta Dental there is a provider
advisory committee and I know that they
are in the process of putting together
who from their provider network will be
included in that so we have two
different processes for providers to be
giving feedback and and keeping an eye
on things
representative Edwards just just just
two thoughts
um I I don't know if you have a response
to these two thoughts but um one on on
that Excel sheet that we're looking for
I think if it were just this ZIP codes
of where you do have a provider rather
than a zip codes where all the zip codes
whether you have a provider or not I
think it's just the zip codes that where
you have a provider that would that
would do my purposes
um and and and then on the other
um I I don't know where we are with the
implementation of the closed loop
referral system and so as I'm just
trying to tie a couple weird puzzle
pieces together I'm just wondering what
the snow show issue if that closed-loop
referral system might be a nice a nice
tool to help you manage uh that
yeah that's a really interesting
connection to point out um I know that
the closed loop referral system is not
up and running
um and I actually don't have today an
update on when we might expect it to be
in effect but you're absolutely right
that I think we would want that to mesh
appropriately with the dental services
counselor
uh thank you Mr chairman I can make your
closing well I get the sense I might be
the thing saying between you and a
weekend so I'll try to be pretty brief
um
um so
um obviously I'm going to speak on
behalf of the Department's perspective
of SB 263 I'm not going to tell you how
you feel about 263.
um so the Department's view of um the
status of SB 263 is that it's pretty
clear that there's a consensus that some
form of the program needs to continue on
the debate of course is centered around
the duration of the program
um uh the community engagement
requirements came up quite a bit
yesterday and it looked like there was a
little bit of sprinkling of funding in
there as well towards the end so
obviously it's moved on to the fiscal
committee unamended on amended I counted
did the spreadsheet counted 32 and 29
were offered oh okay yeah and just to be
clear it's the finance committee not the
fiscal committee that it's working with
entomologist I realized that after I
said I misspoke but thank you for the
correction so the department will
obviously continue to work with the
finance committee and be a resource to
um this body as it moves to the
deliberative process on where this
program is going to go in the future and
I'm happy to take any questions at this
point
that was that good huh you're allocuting
that you stand between us and our
weekend
I will I I will just add that I mean the
it all comes down in the end to the
committee of conference and what the
committee of conference does I mean the
house has a position both on the on the
health care policy the house has a
current position on the budget and the
Senate has a position which aligns with
the house Health Care policy but not
everybody in the house agrees with it so
the committee of conference process is
going to be a very interesting one in
this case I would agree with that and
we're uh and that's that's where it's
all going to happen it's
it irritates me as as one of the policy
committees that we work on good policy
all year long and then all of a sudden
people vanish into a back room and
emerge a week later with either white
smoke or black smoke
something that has things hidden in it
that I find three months later all
division three meetings are open and
noticed I understand that but the
committee of conference process is
slightly different from that so just
Health and Human Services yes
wow okay uh our next meeting is the
fourth Friday of June which is June 23
10 a.m and please convey our regards to